bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait à la chine alors que la
croissance de ce pays s'essouffle après
le confinement de shenzhen puis le
verrouillage de shanghai les économistes
n'excluent plus le risque d'une
récession l'année prochaine le
confinement de la première ville
économique du pays a d'ailleurs entraîné
des protestations inédites de ses
habitants un défi pour 6 jingping alors
que le président chinois se prépare un
troisième mandat à l'occasion du 20ème
congrès du parti communiste cet automne
xi jingping c'est d'ailleurs une
nouvelle fois opposée aux sanctions
prises par l'occident contre la russie
et propose une initiative de sécurité
mondiale qui respecte je cite
l'indivisibilité de la sécurité alors
que vides 300 sécurité la puissance
chinoise est-elle infaillible ou au
contraire montre-t-elle des faiblesses
comme on s'y jingping compte il y
répondre quelle est la position de la
chine sur la sécurité à mondial on en
parle avec mes invités j'ai plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés ursula gauthier
bonsoir dans son grand reporter chef du
service étranger de l'ops et ancienne
correspondante d'ailleurs de l'ops à
pékin à bienvenue à vous en face de vous
pascal boniface bonsoir pascal boniface
merci de revenir dans le débat directeur
et fondateur de l'institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques l'iris
coauteur avec anne sénéquier de
géopolitique du coc vide 19 et c'est
chez eyrolles avec nous également jean
joseph boillot bonsoir économiste
spécialiste de la chine à l'iris membres
du cercle cyclope hauteur de utopie
médine monde aux éditions édiles odile
jacob jean-paul chang bonsoir bienvenue
également à vous économiste spécialiste
de la chine après trois semaines à peu
près de stricte confinement à shanghai
la chine a finalement assoupli
prudemment certaines restrictions
certaines règles ont été allégées la
semaine dernière récit en images vilalta
ramé
déambuler dans une épicerie une scène
encore impensable à shanghai il y a
quelques jours dans la capitale
économique de la chine la vie reprend
lentement son cours et surtout le
travail les autorités de la ville ont
dressé une liste de plus de 600
entreprises dites stratégiques
qui ont été autorisés à reprendre leurs
activités
comme cette usine du fabricant américain
de voitures tesla
nous allons progressivement augmenter
notre capacité de production dans les
trois ou quatre prochains jours jusqu'à
atteindre la pleine capacité sur une
seule et chrétiens quitte à dormir à l'
usine comme ce sera le cas ici pour
respecter la politique du zéro qu'ovide
imposées par le gouvernement chinois
tout en relançant l'économie à lui seul
un mois de confinement strict à shanghai
a fait perdre 0,4 point de croissance à
l'ensemble de la chine pour cette année
l'assouplissement du confinement
concerne les habitants des quartiers qui
n'ont pas connu de 4go vit depuis deux
semaines soit environ 12 millions de
personnes qui peuvent désormais sortir
de chez elle mais uniquement dans leur
quartier pour se promener ou se
réapprovisionner 13 millions d'habitants
reste toujours confinés chez eux et
dépendant des livreurs pour ce qui est
de la nourriture ce supermarché
carrefour isolé du reste de la ville
doit gérer 3000 envois par jour est la
gérante n'a pas d'autre choix que de
dormir sur place
je vais certainement rester jusqu'à la
fin peu importe quand l'épidémie se
termine je resterai dans le supermarché
pour diriger mon personnel et si je suis
autorisé à sortir la première chose que
je vais faire et de rentrer chez moi
pour voir mes parents
selon les autorités de la ville le
nombre de cas de co vide est en baisse
mais les observateurs indépendants
affirment le contraire selon les
chiffres officiels il y aurait moins de
20 morts dus qu'aux vie 19,1 shanghai
depuis le début de la pandémie
pascal boniface pourquoi cette politique
zéro co vide se poursuit-elle en chine
parce que le chef a toujours raison
parce qu'effectivement elle a prouvé son
inefficacité et même un pays comme la
nouvelle zélande dans lequel il était
plus facile la faire respecter a montré
que ça ne marche pas parce que dès qu'il
y ait un cas de co vide qui réapparaît
on bloque tout le pays alors à l'échelle
de la chine c'est très gênant mais comme
dit jean ping a décidé que c'était zéro
coville est que dans un premier temps
ç'a fonctionné parce qu'effectivement
dans un premier temps la chine a moins
souffert du coc vite que les pays euro
bien que les états unis pour ne pas
parler de l'amérique latine et donc
revenir sur cette politique serait
remettre en cause quelque part son
infaillibilité et à quelque temps avant
le congrès qui devrait lui donner un
troisième mandat le remettre un petit
peu à l'âme dans les pas finalement de
mao tsé toung il ne veut pas avouer
qu'il a tort il persiste dans l'erreur
ce qui est quand même très coûteux non
dans l'erreur vous dites oui c'est tout
de même une erreur ça donnait cher la
preuve c'est que et surtout c'est que ça
suscite un mécontentement qui s'exprime
il ya des cas où les chinois étaient pas
très content mais là ils l'ont exprimé
parce que mal et chinoise sont d'accord
pour subir certaines restrictions si on
les laisse circuler consommer
tranquillement si on touche là est bien
le pacte entre les dirigeants et la
population est rompu ursula gauthier le
pacte et est rompu ou pas entre les
dirigeants et la population parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un peu inédit
d'avoir entendu tous ces témoignages de
chinois on a vu également sur les
réseaux sociaux des cris de détresse
enfin c'était assez assez terrible et
puis effectivement des séparations entre
les parents et les enfants déconfinement
pendant des semaines entières est-ce que
d'abord c'est nouveau c'est seulement en
tant qu'enseignants et son ballet
contentement c'est pas nouveau on se
souvient un de ceux du mit qui avait
visité des villes et où des grands tours
il y avait des gens qui au lieu
d'applaudir à était en train de crier
leur leur
leur mécontentement c'est qu'elle
n'avait plus des affrontements avec les
policiers ce qui est nouveau oui ce qui
est nouveau c'est qui c'est que ils sont
ensemble et que quand le soir quand ils
se mettent à taper sur les sur les
casseroles ça fait un boucan absolument
monstrueux et c'est une façon de
protester contre le système ce qui va
avec le zéro co vide c'est que la chine
n'a plus que ça d'une certaine façon
pour arrêter un moment où par exemple il
ya une flambée du coût vite parce que
ils n'ont pas de bons vaccins alors que
ils ont été très ils ont été parmi les
premiers à avoir un vaccin mais
apparemment il n'est pas efficace il l'a
pas été il n'y a pas eu de campagne de
vaccination est donc en réalité pour
aujourd'hui s'il voulait sortir du zéro
co vide il faudrait qu'ils admettent et
d'apporter des vaccins américains
européens et ça aussi ce serait une
énorme perte de face pour si jean ping
jeu jean joseph boillot on les a vus
d'ailleurs dans l'immense hall du web
expo exhibition center to scellier
aligné à shanghai ces témoignages sur
d'ailleurs la saleté c'est même assez
assez étonnant est ce qu'il pourrait
effectivement faire changer la politique
ces témoignages non je crois que ce qui
a été dit par les deux interlocuteurs
précédents ce qui est une question
politique un peu centrale qui est la
légitimité du chef qui est à l'échelle
internationale le risque de compromettre
ce qui est quand même la fameuse
diplomatie de covin vous vous rappelez
ou du vaccin ou la chine hong kong et
rédacteur mondial de très très loin des
vaccins
maintenant je pense qu'il faut faire
attention il ya un joaillier en chine
qui évolue très vite et j'ai des amis à
shanghai que j'ai appelé pour cette
émission spécialement alors ils sont pas
tous jeunes un peu plus vieux que moi et
je dois dire qu'ils sont plutôt
conservateurs et qu' ils m'ont sorti
cette phrase qu'il n'est pas idiot de
connaître sauver une existence c'est
plus que construire une pagode à cet
étage cet extrait de pérégrination vers
l'ouest il ya aussi en chine une
aversion au risque
donc il ya un chef qui est la version à
avoir tort mais il ya aussi je pense une
aversion au risque et dolly et ça peut
expliquer pourquoi pourquoi vous avez à
la fois une exaspération et en
particulier de la population
relativement jeune quand vous regardez
vous voilà celle de mois en mois
maintenant une question d'âge il ya
vraiment je crois une chine a peu coupé
en deux et puis vous avez une radio une
préférence pour le risque le fait est
que si on compare trois grandes zones
émergentes ça aussi intéressant de
comparer la chine par rapport à l'inde
et par rapport à l'afrique
l'afrique vit avec le co vide et pour
l'instant les dégâts humains dégâts
sanitaires sont les dégâts économiques
sont relativement contenue population
jeune aussi en afrique avant population
très jeune par contre dans le cas de
l'inde il ya eu quand même 1 5 6
millions de morts officiellement
maintenant on dit 4 millions en fait ces
cinq à six millions de morts est un pays
qui a été sonnée sonné véritablement
donc je pense que les chinois sont des
gens assez pragmatiques les leaders
chinois sont assez pragmatique il y à
sauver l'économie c'est un des on y
reviendra son travail à leur jeu c'est
très important de trouver l'équilibré le
fameux ying ans entre sauver l'économie
et d'un autre côté pair que comme on n'a
pas de stratégie alternative pour
l'instant eh bien on continue cette
stratégie zéro comme id donc pour vous
ce n'est pas un échec vous écoutez fois
il accepte en tout cas je ne pense pas
jean paul ii chang votre votre avis
justement c'est un échec ou pas cette
politique zéro co vide et finalement
c'est ces détresses et contestation est
ce que c'est un peu nouveau non je
considère que c'est très lourd pour les
habitants de shanghai en ce moment en
tout cas parce que moi aussi je suis en
conflit communication quotidienne depuis
un mois et demi avec mais tous mes
camarades d'école de mon enfance parce
que j'ai passé mon enfance à shanghai
ils sont toujours là encore et je vois
bien leur réaction de à la fois enfin
c'est très partagée dans l'ensemble il
n'y a pas vraiment de contestation
radicale de ce genre de choses mais a
quand même un agacement qui se fait
quotidiennement sur on peut pas sortir
il faut tenir en même temps il ya des
réactions très compliqué comme un peu
ici d'ailleurs quand il ya eu des
périodes de confinement il ya des
dirigeants qui sont très agacés par les
ceux qui sont testés positifs et qu'ils
veulent pas quitter le quartier donc la
crise d'être en fait la cause les
rapports sociaux deviennent un peu plus
compliqué mars à 10h conditions c'est
une société où et quand même très
humaine donc les gens réagissent chacun
un peu
le chiffre rond un peu ces conditions
sociales sa façon de sa place aussi
conservateur que ceux de jean joseph
boillot non mais je suis je partage
beaucoup de ce qui a été dit est immense
et pas s'est il met l'accent
effectivement sur la population active
pour la vaccination c'est vrai qu'il ya
une gigantesque campagne de vaccination
quand même machine aussi mais ils ont
pris ils ont ils donné la priorité à la
population active en vue de la reprise
économique et ils ont délaissé un peu
les gens qui étaient âgés mais ceci dit
mais mes amis qui ont mon âge c'est à
dire au delà de 70 ans bah ils sont tous
vaccinés depuis depuis quelques temps
vacciner est confiné donc à chaque fois
il pratique toujours encore le le sait
toujours tester isolé et le problème
isolement devient vraiment un gros
problème de comment dire de
handicap pour la vie quotidienne pour
plein plein de gens donc et puis isolés
ils ont pas trouvé mieux que de sortir
des gens de leurs appartements pour les
mettre dans des centres ça est ce que
vous avez dit
je ne me sens pas encore manifestement
des problèmes d'hygiène enfin tout ce
que tout ça les raconte cela étant lui
même si un départ en d1 séparation des
parents des anciennes croûtes et cela
étant l'humeur est en mauvaise
effectivement d'une façon générale la
majorité des gens se plaignent quand
même de ce cycle de cela la qualité de
l'alimentation qui livrait
éventuellement il y en a qui sont
contents suivant les quartiers on reçoit
plus ou moins des choses etc mais
s'il n'y a pas pour le moment je pense
qu'il faut pas surinterpréter ni
idéologiquement ni politiquement
finalement la situation en tout cas une
chose est sûre c'est ça coûte cher à
l'économie chinoise s'est confinement
jean joseph boillot puisque vous êtes le
super économistes de ceux de ce plateau
verrouillage de shanghai qui a entraîné
si j'ai bien compris une pagaille un
jury lu ça dans les chaînes logistiques
qui ont donc pas pousser les usines à
fermer une usine tesla d'ailleurs qui
avait fermé a repris du service mais les
salariés vont y vivre 24 heures sur 24
donc là aussi pour rester à l'abri du
coc vide on peut dire que c'est tout de
même un confinement fort taux de
croissance dont qui est tombée hier 4 8%
au premier trimestre par rapport au
premier trimestre de l'an der et donc
c'est plutôt un bon taux de croissance
mais manifestement il masque une chute
importante en activité au mois de mars
et les ventes de détail ont reculé en
mars de 3 5% les importations ont
diminué en mars là aussi pour la
première fois depuis un an elles ont
donc ralenti la production
manufacturière a été freinée et les
économistes parlent d'une éventuelle
peut-être une récession l'année
prochaine
si on regarde bien la grande réunion on
va dire economics et s'est déroulé le
scat et 5 mars s'appelle il ya un gourou
et c'est 5000 à peu près et caciques qui
viennent de l'assemblée nationale du
congrès pour discuter de la situation
économique est là
où on avait commencé déjà revoir un peu
à la baisse le taux de croissance mais
c'était début mars c'est à dire pas de
guerre en ukraine et puis pas sous
confinement donc les chiffres que vous
avez cités sont des chiffres du passé en
réalité ce qu'on sait très bien c'est
que c'est pas seulement d'ailleurs
chandail ma famille dans la région du
sichuan et d'instituts and songs chine
qui est la deuxième voire la première
grande ville en chine est très touchée
aussi par sa d'olivia à mon avis tout à
fait fondé cette idée que la dernière
prévision du fmi de 4,8 pour cent pour
l'an prochain doit être très clairement
revu à la baisse quel est le seul moteur
qui tire encore un peu aujourd'hui
l'économie chinoise c'est le paradoxe ce
sont les exportations l'année dernière
la chine n'a jamais exporté autant
elle et premier exportateur mondial 15%
à elle toute seule et donc le risque
c'est qu'avec ce type de gestion 0
qu'ovide le seul moteur soit celui qui
justement est une faiblesse pour la
chine parce qu'elle dépend du reste du
monde les faux bien regarder la carte du
coc vides et des zones qui ont été
confinés les grandes zones exportatrices
c'est à shanghai s'est passé en gare et
les grandes zones exportatrices sont les
ports de ningbo et c et e vous
n'entendez pas parler il faut toujours
faire bien attention à savoir qu'ils
exportent c'est ce que vous dites oui
ursula gauthier vous n'avez pas l'air
darwin on le moteur principal de
l'économie c'est bien connu depuis déjà
longtemps pas seulement depuis le coc
vide ou la guerre en ukraine ce sont les
investissements en
infrastructure sécurisée et ce qui reste
son moteur
investissement la seule chose qui aurait
continué d'investir en infrastructures
et mais le problème c'est que c'est un
moteur qui est essoufflé puisque la
chine est saturé d'investissement en
réalité et donc il avait plusieurs
effectivement cordes sur lesquels il
pouvait jouer il y avait les
exportations il y avait un tout petit
peu de consommation des ménages et il y
avait ces fameuses infrastructures les
investissements d'état mais ça c'est des
moteurs qui sont tous en cours
d'essouflement c'est pour ça qu'il ya un
problème systémique de
l'économie chinoise je vous fait réagir
mais avant on va écouter xi jingping qui
justement a évoqué aujourd'hui à dans un
forum économique cette situation
économique
les fondements de l'économie chinoise en
termes de folie résilience de potentiel
aliciens le team de vastes marge de
manoeuvre est délibérément à long terme
resteront inchangés qui vont lui fournir
une grande dynamique pour la stabilité
et la reprise de l'économie mondiale et
des opportunités de marché plus la
viande hachée mais moins que si mme
vallin là j'ai une phobie ratant sa
confiance et de sa volonté de se
réformer et de s'ouvrir pour le sujet
phare le chemin à le perdre à
jean-paul champions plutôt rassurant
évidemment
enfin bon
je pense que je le sens je veux apporter
si je faisais un peu d un peu de vide
votre touche un peu différente de ce qui
a été dit on néglige une chose c'est que
en fait le la croissance chinoise la
croissance du pib chinois a été de 4 8%
sur le 1er trimestre de 2022 le cadre de
8% sur le 1er trimestre ce qui est
intéressant c'est de regarder quelles
sont les composantes de cette croissance
dans cette croissance de 4,8 3 3 c'est
déjà presque 70% est constitué par la
consommation
1,2 1,3 pour cent de ces 4 8% correspond
à des investissements
et le net de du commerce extérieur c'est
à dire l'exportation - importations ne
compte que pour ses 11 2% dans la
croissance cela veut dire que le moteur
principal de la croissance aujourd'hui
et depuis déjà quelques années et c'est
l'erreur que les occidentaux ne veulent
pas voir c'est bien la taille du marché
domestique le marché de la consommation
s'est grippé avec le confirme alors
justement c'est pour ça je pense que la
situation est plus disons critique en ce
qui concerne ce facteur de la croissance
c'est à dire que vides rupture de chaîne
de production du coup effectivement les
produits au bouddha chaîne arrive
difficilement sur le marché ce genre de
choses c'est la difficulté principale
alors qu'en ce qui concerne
l'infrastructure en fait ils ont même
avancé la date de lancement des méga
projets donc cette année est aussi
consciente de l'exportation finalement
en fait ils ont concerné à gauche
constater que ça continue à augmenter
mais la contribution à la croissance au
taux de croissance si vous voulez
aujourd'hui repose sur la consommation
est inquiétant ou pas pour la chine
disons que c'est si un problème sur
lequel on peut avoir des inquiétudes
si ça se rétablit pas rapidement parce
que c'est quand même effectivement le le
le le moteur aujourd'hui 2 du taux de
croissance en chine
c'est vrai pléthore d'infrastructures on
a parlé de l'éclatement d'une bulle
spéculative
il ya quelques temps elle n'a pas éclaté
mais il ya un peu de marge de manoeuvre
en termes d'infrastructures ya trop de
logements il ya des routes qui sont pas
utilisés et c est la croissance les
exportations c'est cet arrêté la suite
elle convient de citer la crise mondiale
et du coup il y avait plus la l'économie
repart au niveau mondial et donc la
chine devraient en bénéficier
mais c'est vrai que pour des raisons
aussi de satisfaire les consommateurs et
citoyens chinois on tablait plutôt sur
une reprise de la consommation interne
qui est stoppée ce que si vous êtes
bloqué chez vous sans pouvoir sortir
vous avez du mal à à consommer donc il
ya certainement là un retour aussi aux
exportations mais la mauvaise nouvelle
pour la chine c'est que du fait de la
guerre en ukraine lancé par
la russie il ya deux postes qui vont
coûter beaucoup plus cher à la chine que
d'habitude ce sont les produits
alimentaires et l'énergie or dans les
deux cas elle est fortement importatrice
de produits alimentaires puisqu'elle à
8% les terres cultivables mondiale pour
22% la population et qu'on sait qu'elle
est déficitaire depuis déjà très
longtemps énergie donc ça elle va y
avoir un renchérissement de l'énergie et
de l'alimentation
et ça va forcément peser sur sa
croissance alors c'est la côte est est
ce que cette nappe pour 6 jingping
justement en vue de troisième mandat en
vue de ce 20ème congrès du parti à
l'automne au lte et je pense que si jean
ping est très inquiète parce qu'en
réalité au sein du parti d'après ce
qu'on peut entendre parce que ce sont
des résidences une boîte noire on sait
pas ce qui se passe au sein du parti
mais il ya quand même des choses qui
sortent part parce que le parti n'est
pas monolithique parce qu'il ya des
tendances et il y a une tendance qui est
pour l'ouverture du marché pour
continuer à commercer avec le monde pour
son tendre un petit peu sur ne pas ne
pas être hostile avec les marchés
principaux de la chine qui sont les
états unis à l'europe donc oui il ya des
gens qui font sortir des informations
elle ces informations laissent penser
qu'il y as peut-être possiblement une
contre-offensive contre 6 du pin que ce
n'est pas si sûr que ça qu'il soit
adoubé au
25ème congrès du parti qui se tient dans
ses 5e 20e eux 20e pack 20e oui je
sautais deux gros dos quelques années et
donc que qu'en réalité
lui il était et il était sur un sur un
nuage en fin tout allait très bien y
compris quand le coville a éclaté
puisque il a fait un rétablissement
extraordinaire il faut dire après les
premiers mauvais moment et puis
maintenant toute sa stratégie se
retourne et évidemment c'est ses
adversaires vont s'en servir et y
compris la guerre en ukraine évidemment
c'est un des gros morceaux sur lesquels
ils vont pouvoir a ployé vous êtes
d'accord justement jean joseph boillot
et c'est très important qu'il a fuit
pour être affaibli par cette situation
xi jingping j'ai vu qu'ils continuent à
sa campagne de purger en tout cas
puisque et une arrestation de l'ancien
ministre chinois de la juste comme
d'habitude contre la corruption parce
qu'il était corrompu non ce qui est dit
est très important parce que
l'économie chinoise est une économie
développée il faut arrêter de dire
qu'elle est en voie de développement etc
même si le pib par habitant reste très
inférieur à ceux des états unis faut
arrêter de penser que les talons de la
prospérité c'est les états unis par
contre en terme de 2,2 d'objectifs pour
la croissance chinoise c'est ce qu'on
appelle la frontière technologique
aujourd'hui la seule solution pour la
chine compte tenu du choc démographique
qui est déjà en cours qui est déjà en
cours le déisme ans la population des
plus de 65 ans va passer quoi de 17% de
la population à 60% pas de la population
par nom d assez mauvais pour la
croissance des actifs bien sûr non mais
la chine est rentré dans cet âge là
c'est pour ça qu'on n'achetez pas
personne n'a acheté le l'objectif de
shillings ping de 6 25% croissance déjà
5% franchement c'est une économie qui
est
quasiment sochaux par rapport à son
potentiel donc là la seule façon de s'en
sortir c'est les investissements
technologiques le rattrapage
technologique est d'ailleurs le but qui
était fixé ces 70 % d'autonomie
technologique en 2025 et
quasiment 100% mais pas avant 2035 ou 50
donc il vaut donc énormément investir
mais qui investissent et pas l'état on
le sait bien que l'état ne peut pas à
lui tout seul générer ce rattrapage
technologique donc il a besoin d'une
économie allez on va dire libre et la sq
est en train de se passer c'est à dire
sur la côte est très important c'est
qu'à cause d'eux le risque politique est
perçue dans l'entourage de jean ping de
cette attaque il est allé on va dire à
droite ça vous va parfois on disait à
gauche pour ce qui est des chinois parce
que c'est l'extrême gauche mais à cause
de cette attaque la
l'investissement dans le rattrapage
technologique ne soit affectée ce qui
d'ailleurs dans les images que vous avez
montré tout à l'heure cependant c'est là
où shanghai joue un rôle très important
la région de shanghai jusqu'à se joue en
règle et c'est elle qui a frappé par le
confinement et donc c'est là dessus que
la chine est en train de buts et par
rapport à cet objectif de rattrapage
technologique donc je crois que c'est
plus que le taux de croissance si vous
voulez ce qui me semble non pas
inquiétants mais poser un problème à
chez jean ping dans sa logique et sa
politique économique c'est risquer de me
menacer ce rattrapage technologique ils
ont près d'accord moi personnellement je
ne parierais pas trop sûr que si vous
voulez la
l'affaiblissement de chine king en ce
moment je pense qu'il a eu une politique
disons assez conséquente en termes de de
lutte contre les ses adversaires à
l'intérêt du parti ce qu'ils appellent
des groupes d'intérêts sûr que tous les
réformes qu'ils ont essayé de mettre en
place sortez chaque fois des vrais
groupes d'intérêts qui avait des
terrains à défendre effectivement aussi
à shanghai même à shanghai vous avez des
représentants de groupes d'intérêts qui
sont très puissants du côté des douanes
des choses de ce genre donc
hostile à la réforme sur quels ils ont
leurs prisons leur terrain de chasse ils
ont ils à pouvoir et que les réformes
qui tendent éventuellement à libéraliser
les réglementations et ses hôtes de la
marde des détenteurs de pouvoirs un
certain nombre de choses et il résiste
il résiste vous savez que ils ont
supprimé plus de 100000 texte par
exemple de loi décrété par les
différents niveaux de gouvernements
locaux ça se fait pas sans
mécontentement de la part d'un certain
nombre de gens qui ont déjà des acquis
des positions de pouvoir donc tout ça
fait effectivement que il ya une
certaine logique donc dans cette espèce
d'affrontements de conflits plus si tim
kring avance dans les réformes qu'il
veut imposer plus effectivement il
suicide n'est entendu un peu deux
enfants suscite de l'opposition
d'hostilité et encore une fois je
rajoute que gérard jodar et même voix
que en fait s'il a décidé effet un
troisième mandat où il a fait passer les
textes autorisant des mandats
c'était un message politique extrêmement
clair il ya déjà trois ans parce qu'il
ya des tas de gens qui étaient tentés de
se dire on va faire le dos rond nous
attendre que la fin du deuxième mandat
et à ce moment là on recommence à l'est
la montagne comme on dit en chinois
n'est ce pas on reviendra à la norme
positions perdues et là le message
politique ses abats détrompez vous j'ai
commencé je vais continuer et j'ai fait
en sorte que je vais continuer jusqu'au
bout il y aura une bataille ou pas la
beauté je ne suis absolument pas
d'accord avec
j'apprécie beaucoup que monsieur john
présente il gémit comme un réformateur
et que les autres comme des comme des
ses opposants au sein du parti comme des
personnes qui tiennent justement juste
alors pré carré de de prébendes en gros
on ne peut pas ramener la la la lutte
qui existent aujourd'hui au sein du
parti juste à cette question là ça c'est
ce que si j been veut faire croire au
monde ce qu'il veut faire croire à la
chine et au monde en réalité il ya
évidemment d'autres enjeux il suffit de
sortir de cette question à la limite
simplement purement économique et se
rendre compte de la chape de plomb qui
l'a fait tomber sur les libertés au à la
base au quotidien qui existait que dont
les chinois a profité au quotidien il y
en a très peu qui reste aujourd'hui est
donc ce n'est pas juste le bon dirigeant
bien éclairé qui est en train d'essayer
de sauver l'économie chinoise en la
mettant sur des voies vertueuse c'est
quelqu'un qui est en train d'établir un
pouvoir extrêmement autoritaire voire
totalitaire non seulement sur le pays
mais sur l'ensemble du parti et c'est
pour ça qu'au sein du parti il y à des
résistances c'est aussi pour ça il a
affiché en tout cas un rapprochement on
va parler un peu relations
internationales avec vladimir poutine
aux jo de pékin on s'en souvient le
président chinois proposent maintenant
on va le voir on va l'écouter une
initiative de sécurité mondiale qui
respecte l'indivisibilité de la sécurité
on sait pas ce que ça veut dire on va en
parler on va l'écouter aussi jean ping
on met un compte dont nous devons
travailler ensemble pour maintenir la
paix et la stabilité dans le monde un
pays bien gouverné est souvent riche
tandis qu'un pays dans le chaos et
souvent frappées par la pauvreté mais je
les fais ont une fois de plus prouvé que
la mentalité de la guerre froide ne
pouvait que détruire le cadre de la paix
mondiale que l'hégémonisme et la
politique de puissance ne pouvait que
compromettre à la paix mondiale et que
la confrontation des blocs de brûlé qui
exacerbait les défis de sécurité au
21ème siècle la chine aimerait proposer
une initiative de sécurité mondiale afin
de promouvoir le monde pour partager les
bonheurs et les malheurs qu'a boniface
qu'elle sera décisive pour dire oui on
prend pas protéger la paix bien sûr en
fait lorsqu'il parle de éviter la
logique des blocs c'est une réponse à
joe biden joe byden n'arrête pas de dire
qu'il faut créer une coalition des
démocraties contre la kth des pays
autoritaires autour de moscou et pékin
et la guerre que la russie a lancé
contre l'ukraine sert ce discours de
maiden puisque les pays européens qui
étaient très réticents en juin 2021
byden est venue en europe sommet du g7
sommet de l'otan il n'a pas arrêté de
dire c'est la chine qui est le problème
les européens ont dit mais la chine
n'est pas dans l'atlantique nord et donc
nous on s'occupe éventuellement de la
russie mais pas de la chine la russie a
fait la guerre tous les pays européens
sont effrayés de ce qui peut se produire
ils ont tous été demandé aux états unis
s'il vous plaît restez revenait soyez
plus présent eh ben il donne à dire oui
d'accord mais il ya un défi ou et pas
écouté sur la russie maintenant il ya un
vrai défi c'est la chine et dont les
pays européens vont être un peu pris
entre le marteau et l'enclume par
rapport à leurs intérêts économiques
leur volonté de ne pas faire une
profession autorise at war et en même
temps de ne pas se couper des états unis
et là on voit bien que jean ping sans ce
danger de venir créer une nouvelle
division du monde qui disent oh l'arrêt
parce qu'il ne compte pas trop sur la
russie pour se défendre par rapport aux
états unis donc ya pas une alliance
aujourd'hui entre la russie et
placé enfin il ya une alliance oui et
non c'est faux les russes ont mécontenté
les chinois en se lançant dans la guerre
parce que ça vient pour les chinois la
première place mondiale qu'il veulent
viendra naturellement par la croissance
économique s'il y a des guerres ça vient
perturber ce jeu normal c'est des jeunes
surtout si ça augmente le prix de
l'essence de l'énergie et des produits
alimentaires et surtout si ça vient
renforcer l'otan et que ça fasse de
l'otan une alliance anti chinoises il va
être bientôt y avoir un sommet de l'otan
je pense qu'on va parler autant de la
chine que de la russie et ça c'est
nouveau ça ça ça monte de plus en plus
évidemment ça ne crée pas exiger une
bible et joseph voilà vous êtes d'accord
lors pékin affirme tout de même que la
souveraineté de l'ukraine doit être
respectée c'est ce que dit xi jingping
mais que les préoccupations de la russie
en matière de sécurité doivent être
respectés également alors est ce que ça
change la géopolitique en fait ils
essayent d'avoir une position un peu
médiane dans la presse ce chinois j'ai
trouvé cela il ya une petite semaine des
oeuvres de perdition ne peuvent conduire
au salut des oeuvres de perdition ne
peuvent conduire au salut ce a dénoncé
sa cible et c'était poutine poutine
voilà ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
est essentiel que vous dites qu'ils sont
très critiques de cette baisse ont
besoin d'interaction éthique de poutine
ayant besoin de stabilité dont ils ont
besoin et totalisera près aux intérieurs
ils ont besoin de stabilité pour
rattraper notamment l'économie chinoise
il faut regarder que l'état de
l'armement et c'est pour ça que cette
gamme est très importante montrent que
la chine est très loin en arrière elle a
peut-être la quantité mais elle n'a pas
du tout un armement qui lui
permettraient aujourd'hui de ce su
trouver dans un environnement hostile
donc elle a tendance déshabille d'art
aussi parce que c'est un allié
absolument essentiel parce que sur le
plan économique c'est un fournisseur
aussi très importants de matières rares
et c est par contre elle est en train
moi je le vois très nettement sur le
plan économique deux seront disposés sur
les pays émergents et elle a même élargi
les pays émergents au moyen-orient c'est
quand même la première fois qu'
aujourd'hui une puissance et la 9e du
monde l'arabie saoudite dit je vais
effectivement effectuer mais règlement
en yuan ça c'est quelque chose de tout à
fait nouveau il y a plus de quarante
piges en avait cité ça quand est une
spécialiste de la banque de france 12h40
d'une quarantaine il ya plus de 50 pays
qui ont aujourd'hui des accords de swap
ce qui est tout à fait nouveau donc
c'est ça que la chine est en train
d'opérer et en opérant cela elle est
obligée de rentrer dans le sorte de nini
du monde en développement le déni c'est
à dire
on y occident ni russie on est pas
content avec la façon dont la russie
finalement compromet aujourd'hui
l'intégrité tapas et quand même un
rapprochement avec vladimir poutine aux
jo en fin non attendez on vous parlait
de la chine je parle du monde émergent
la chine ne peut pas ne peut pas se
couper du monde émergent elle voudrait
en est le chef de file menant tout cas
sur le plan économique c'est ça qui lui
procure l'essentiel de sa puissance
économique pour l'instant elle est
obligée de travailler si vous voulez un
peu en ligne angles en équilibre entre
d'un côté un allié stratégique la russie
et de l'autre côté le monde en
développement qui est l'élément clé et
si vous écoutez bien la proposition moi
je crois que c'est une proposition qui
vise à non pas recréer les non-alignés
mais qui vise à recréer à l'échelle
mondiale une sorte de grand félin
prendre le leadership des non alignés a
heurté la gauthière
excusez-moi si jean ping a déclaré une
amitié sans limites sans limite avec
poutine poutine est allé assister à la
cérémonie d'ouverture des jo
évidemment on ne sait pas ce que poutine
lui a dit on ne sait pas mais on suppose
qu'il a quand même dû lui faire
comprendre que parce que poutine devait
s'assurer que sur son flanc oriental et
bien il n'aurait pas d'ennuis avec la
chine au moment où il attaquait sur le
flanc occidentale en ukraine donc on
suppose qu'il a dû lui dire quelque
chose il ya plein d'observateurs les
américains sont persuadés par exemple
que il l'a prévenu maintenant c'est si
tu me dis encore une fois un le parti
n'est pas monolithique sait si jean ping
alors si jean ping partage avec poutine
quelque chose de fondamental une
détestation sans borne de du système
démocratique de l'ordre mondial basé sur
ballons albert biologique est une
idéologie en revanche la chine la chine
en tant que pays puissance s'est
toujours méfié la russie donc évidemment
que du point de vue de ces deux du
régime il y a une position qui est voilà
entre le marteau et l'enclume ij havre
michou mais en réalité c'est si poutine
avait réalisé son but c'est à dire prix
qui est en trois jours renverser le
gouvernement et cetera et cetera
évidemment si jean ping pouvait dire
regardez c'est bien il a raison et
d'ailleurs ça existe ça ça ça fortifie
mon souhait de d'en faire autant à
taïwan puisque nous avons l'enjeu
taïwanais mais en même temps si je ne
voulais pas une victoire trop brillante
non plus de poutine parce que une russie
très puissante à ses frontières il ya
des milliers de kilomètres de frontière
commune entre la russie et la chine
c'est quand même une sorte de cauchemar
aussi donc la chine a toujours été
partagée par rapport à ce que peut faire
poutine
puissante par rapport à la chine là
c'est terminé la russie est mineur par
rapport à la chine est donc ce qui gêne
les russes d'ailleurs il pourrait
devenir un vassal de la saison enfin
quand même toit la guerre ça serait
confirme d'approvisionnement
énergétiques la chine ne va pas
compenser l'europe espère diversifier
leur approvisionnement que de se mettre
uniquement dans les mains des russes
mais le rapport est tellement inégal
entre la russie et la chine sur tous les
points y compris sur le plan
technologique mais sur le plan
stratégique non parce que regarder
comment poutine a repris le contrôle de
l'asie centrale avec ce qui s'est passé
ben en asie centrale juste avant les
événements il ya 25 me sens pas
en voiture mais il faut jamais
sous-estimer les raisons profondes de
rapprochement entre les russes et les
chinois j'ai toujours et voulu attirer
l'attention dès les années 2010 2012 sur
le fait qu'il ya une convergence
d'intérêts entre les deux pays la chine
à la recherche de la sécurité
énergétique s'est rapproché de la russie
avec tous les gazoducs et les oléoducs
qui existe depuis six années là et
qu'ils ont continué aujourd'hui pour
diversifier schisme en les sources
d'approvisionnement d'énergie de côté
même culturellement ils ont d
idéologiquement il ya des points de
rapprochement qu'on ne soupçonne pas les
deux peuples ont choisi des formes de
gouvernement n'ont pas imposé de
l'extérieur c'est eux qui ont inventé le
même le régime virus avec la tradition
de sa risques puis le soviet si j'ose
dire bon et les chinois ont une
expérience semblable avec les
communismes donc les des relations
qu'ils font que les deux pays se
comprenne bien qu'en ait eu la
révolution culturelle en chine des
russes il disait on comprenait cette
tragédie parce que nous on a connu ça
dans les années 37 38 donc tous ces
points de reconnaissance des marqueurs
immédiat dans les deux peuples il faut
pas le sous-estimer
et pour dernière chose c'est aussi quand
même nos efforts ce n'est pas pour les
régimes les peuples je parle bien les
peuples parce que dans les années d'être
d'isolement de la chine entre 49 et
79 je veux dire tout ce qui était
culture étrangère venait de la russie
n'oubliez pas qu'il ya toute une
génération de chinois ils connaissaient
par coeur mouche keane
chostakovitch et ses atouts mais il ya
en beaucoup plus qu'un double pensée
dans la génération des chinois de
d'aujourd'hui et dernière chose on dit
ici de temps en temps il faut pas
pousser la rustique dans les bras de la
chine moi je tairai vous êtes en train
de pousser la chine dans les bras de la
russie aussi parce qu'il ya quand même
eu les alliances militaires hocus le
quad etc avant l'ukraine donc quand les
chinois voient avancée des alliances
militaires sans tenir compte de leur
conception de sécurité ils comprennent
davantage les russes qui avance ou même
type d'argument alors justement ils
viennent de signer deux signé pascal
boniface la chine un accord avec les
îles salomon récemment en matière de
sécurité justement alors là c'est un
revers après l'australie oui c'est pour
les états unis ils ont encore mais la
chine est très très présente dans le
pacifique parce que il y a beaucoup de
micro état qui finalement n'ont pas
besoin enfin qu'il est facile de
les avoir des relations amicales et est
contre sp quelques dons des
constructions etc on parle de djibouti
du pacifique fortement c'est
une très forte présence une base
militaire chinoise à djibouti voilà et
avec les états unis djibouti à une base
militaire américaine française et
chinoise et donc effectivement c'est
quand même nouveau pour la chine avant
une base militaire à l'étranger
dans le pacifique c'est un terrain de
chasse extrêmement important pour la
chine a reçu quelques états
reconnaissent à taïwan au fur et à
mesure ils ne reconnaissent plus taiwan
et effectivement ça fait quand même un
paquet de voix à l'onu pour pas cher et
ça fait ça fait aussi contrepoids à la
présence américaine donc là la chine est
très présente diplomatiquement et
économiquement et culturellement les
instituts confucius qui sont ouverts
l'invitation d'univers fait part de la
route de la soie salle n'était pas au
départ sur les routes de la soie vous
allez au delà soir c'est un fil alors le
mais ouvre donc les allemands sont
devenus effectivement partie du
financement fait des financements des
roues de la soul mais c'est la stratégie
chinoise qui continuent là dessus bien
sûr bien sûr régulièrement mon année
rejoint puisqu'ils étaient dix au plan
économique le pib de la russie
d'accord c'est deux tiers seulement du
total des exportations chinoises
donc voyez on n'est plus du tout on ne
joue plus du tout dans la même cour par
contre c'est sur le flanc occidentale de
la chine un élément central bien
évidemment alors je disais il ya 25
millions de chinois en asie centrale
c'est possible que les russes donnent
l'impression de contrôler et l'asie
centrale mais pas trop j'aimerais juste
terminée sur un point ils salomon en
réalité il y à tout un ensemble
d'accords qui sont en train d'être tissé
sur le mode et simplement on n'a pas
parlé du sri lanka or c'est très
important de sous oui c'est très
important sri lanka bien de faire un
défaut de paiement or ce défaut de
paiement une grosse partie en fait est
dû à la chine et notamment pour
l'installation d'une base au départ
c'était un port commercial est en vérité
tout le monde sait très bien que c'est
une base militaire sinon la coop david
assure chinoise et canon et comment
c'est très important de comprendre cela
comment pékin va gérer cette dette avec
les pays en développement elle va très
probablement un peu partout faire une
sorte de donnant donnant et elle en
afrique déjà elle le fait en afrique et
c'est là où il faut être très très
vigilant parce qu'il peut y avoir un
déséquilibre en faveur effectivement de
ce qu'on appelle despotisme oriental
quel point commun entre la russie la
chine et ses totalitarisme on verra en
tout cas il ya un despotisme oriental la
queue très nette dans cette région du
monde alors pour en revenir justement au
sujet de ce débat est ce qu elle a des
failles est ce que ce système a des
failles un mot de conclusion chacun je
commence par vous pascal boniface est ce
qu'il ya des failles parce que c'est la
fin a sonné d'argile non pas aux pieds
d'argile c'est un colosse mais qui a des
failles et notamment la colère
grandissante de la population même
malgré la crispation autoritaire si le
pacte vous consommez je dirige n'est pas
respectée ça va être problématique
j'emploie de change je savais que ce que
dit pascal
mais il ya des vulnérabilités c'est vrai
voilà alors c'est la côte est c'est un
régime qui a beaucoup de résilience
c'est vrai il l'a montré à de nombreuses
reprises il a été capable de rebondir y
compris à des moments où c'était
dramatique et on se disait voilà c'était
par exemple en 89 quand les autres pays
du bloc de l'est sont tombés là on
donnait pas cher de pékin et ils ont
trouvé le moyen de rebondir
simplement je pense qu'ils sont arrivés
au terme de leur modèle de développement
et de leur modèle politique et qu' il
est en train de craquer alors on ne sait
pas quand ça va tomber mais je pense que
ça va tomber jean joseph boillot oui de
deux grandes limites la limite
démographique dont on a parlé qu'on le
voit tous les jours désormais en chine
et la deuxième c'est la limite
technologique la chine a besoin de temps
et la question de savoir est ce qu'elle
aura le temps par rapport à ces deux
défis
je ne voudrais pas dire qu'elle va
craquer je n'en sais rien du tout ce
qu'on voit simplement c'est que c'est un
empire la chine est géré comme dans un
empire et qu'en général à l'échelle de
l'histoire les empires présente comme
très vite et d'être précisément des
empires et le problème de la chine sera
celui d'une transition politique et
économique
chez jean ping n'est pas l'homme de la
situation c'est très clair n'est pas
l'homme de la situation c'est jean ping
je vais rebondir juste j'ai l'impression
qu'il a les choses bien en main mais je
peux me tromper l'espace de la
transition économique et politique dont
je parle uniquement de cela sinon il a
les choses en très en main merci
beaucoup en tout cas tous les quatre
jours joseph boillot merci beaucoup à
vous jean paul chang pascal boniface
ursula gauthier merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivi il reste avec tout sur
france 24